so how about this like i know you and
royce better than i know joelle and joe
i know you guys to be men of high
integrity high character
you guys have have the longevity you've
had in this industry for a reason
um
never know [ __ ] involving y'all's
names right um
you know i can understand the
frustration of royce's side saying hey
that's that's our logo that you guys are
putting on the front of that and you
guys just
bombard us with this album that i had no
idea was coming right and it's our logo
on fire
you know he has a to me he has he has a
right to be emotional about that and to
feel a way about that would you agree
um absolutely
and like you guys obviously know that
like you said you said i you said i i
can give i i knew that this i didn't
give them a heads up so i understood
that they they're that there's going to
be an emotional reaction right and you
kind of accounted for that already right
no i i i give them room to react to that
you know what i'm saying um
you know i'm watching how i'm watching
the reactions you know what i'm saying
because
if it was me
you know but i feel differently but if
it was me i'm i don't care they can use
the slaughterhouse logo for whatever
they want to use it for you know what i
mean like i said who owns that logo well
what happened was they're saying that
ownership was really relinquished to the
group later i haven't seen no paperwork
stating that
um we got jerked in the beginning you
know somebody
um
owned it that was not a part of the
group
you feel me so somebody on the
management team owned it
to my knowledge someone who is a part of
the group's management groups management
okay you know what i mean so
um right off rip that should have been
that that's that's a red flag but i
heard that they made it right and
relinquished it to the group when we
went to shady i'm not sure i've never
seen the paperwork on that when i go and
look look up the trademark i don't see
our names anywhere mentioned on the
trademark so i i don't know who owns it
and if they really feel some type of way
somebody would just sue you yeah and i
would just take it off the cover and
keep going yeah you know what i'm saying
because this story is going to be told
they can't stop it they can't you know i
feel like they have efforts to try to
do damage control over something that
they haven't even heard yet
you know what i mean and it's like um
you know
this story needs to be told for us
on our fans
i think the fans need closure and i
think y'all need clothes i need hella
closure kev i'm gonna tell you because
guess what every [ __ ] time you do an
interview or joelle does an interview or
royce does an interview or
everyone's asking what's up with what's
up with glass house what's up with
slaughterhouses it'll never go away
until you just close the chapter and say
burn the book you have to
and that's what i had to do man like a
lot of people like you burning the
shirts up on the video no listen
i'm trying to get this low vibration
[ __ ] out of my life forever i'm in a
whole nother place i'm six years sober i
haven't i've been you know in master
classes i've been you know trying to
better myself get to get myself into a
better headspace just be a better human
being period i need this negative
triggering [ __ ] to [ __ ] out of my life
for forever i don't want to go back to
it they could do whatever they want with
it and that was my that was my intention
so just
me symbolically
tearing slaughterhouse down out of my
life you know i'm saying me personally
if they want to uphold it and they want
to put it on a pedestal they could do
that all day and i'm they're not gonna
hear a peep for me you know i mean but
me personally i had to get it out of my
life because every single time we spoke
about it talked about it tried to do it
again and it didn't happen and all the
interviews and then post a [ __ ] piece
of toast on instagram and people still
like yo what's up that toast is cool but
what's up with slaughterhouse you know
it's just too much man you're over it
i'm over it it needs to go you know what
i'm saying i mean listen i respect it
man